une image furtive une archive de 73 un
portrait de votre père jean marie le pen
qui vient de créer le front national
vous avez 5 ans
[Musique]
vous êtes la petite dernière avec le
gros nounours dans les bras et le
chandail à rayures et donc pour vous une
première apparition dans un reportage
politique sans que vous l'ayez souhaité
oui c'est vrai on a on a été très vite
mis devant les caméras mais à cette
époque c'était c'était la grande époque
enfin le début de l'époque reagan de
l'époque
où on est et ont montré la vie de
famille en fête est donc tout au long de
la vie politique de mon père on a
souvent fait l'objet de reportages mais
ça c'est effectivement la première image
avec le chien rainbow que vous ne voyez
pas mais que vous entendez et dans cet
appartement qui était un appartement
assez modeste du 15e arrondissement
devant lequel nous vivions et qui plus
tard sera le logement qui
explosera qui sera dévastée
[Musique]